I have a need for mr. deeds like Gary
Cooper movie no the Adam Sandler remake
you have a way better Jesse impression
at me Wow hey audience [ __ ] where you
talk about Need for Speed yo I don't
want to cook today yo mister audience
I'm Ryan writes [ __ ] and my name is
cherry yo welcome to reasons to see it's
what we give you reasons to see and not
to see [ __ ] need for speed so you and I
are gonna hang out [ __ ] okay so we saw
a movie yeah a movie that will never
leave my movie and a half it's like one
movie plus half of another movie and a
bunch of other genres - yeah no it's
like six movies and we are of course
talking about Ned for spent and I am so
excited to talk about this fella
I had a blast yeah it was one hell of a
good time I'm telling you that right now
[ __ ] the 23 or 24 percent of Rotten
Tomatoes this movie is entertainment
yeah I mean like I understand but at the
same time it's like this movie doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything resembling
logic or physics or consistency of any
kind keeping to a tone it's just a
free-for-all of ridiculousness and then
is the reason to see it like it yeah and
unlike whatever genre they're trying to
do at that time they commit to it with
every possible way especially the music
and this film you know it really does
have the spirit of life of a kid in high
school who got his friends together
because they love cars and they were
like okay we're gonna do this scene it's
like really intense cuz you cuz he died
so we're gonna put some intense music
yeah no no do you should get naked you
should make into this part alright it's
gonna be really funny hey I like that
Linkin Park song let's good put it over
the really intense part cuz it's gonna
be so cool right like the actuals
hoes music was just ridiculous like oh
my god like every scene like a scene
would start out just be like okay this
is a good dialogue we got going on and
then they blast some super heavy
dramatic music every other thing is the
height of drama it's either a heroic
song a journey of growth or like heavy
ash it's like before anyone's even lost
anything that that the official theme
song of we've triumphed but with so much
loss comes in this movie like really
earnestly seems to believe in how
important it's trying to be oh yeah no
this movie does not have like a sense of
humor about itself but yet it's really
funny and entertaining yeah not in a way
like a Transformers movie takes itself
way too seriously
but it's just like this film really
commits to everything it's like it
believes everything is as heavy and has
as much gravitas as it thinks it does
but in a way where it's totally like oh
you guys by the way there's a lot of
things you're like what why do they just
do that it doesn't matter
didn't it need to do that thousands of
lives are endangered
just cuz yeah it would be a lot easier
if they just did it the regular way okay
example number one there's this one
point where they're like we need to save
time so they fill their gas on the
freeway and they play the most
triumphant music when they do it and
then like ten minutes later they're
stopping at a gas station all of a
sudden they just get the gas then who
needs to save that much time it's two
and a half minutes of your life I rarely
ever say this cuz it's rarely ever
actually true but this movie really kind
of just doesn't make any sense really
cause like I couldn't actually tell what
that scene was about it was like they
did that gas thing on the freeway and
they kept talking about this is gonna
add time to the trip but it's gonna be a
short cut we don't have time and all of
a sudden they're gassing up I don't
quite know why he's driving this Mustang
across the country I don't quite know
why anybody agreed to let him do this
but he's doing it okay first off Aaron
Paul he is awesome yeah he can act like
he could be a leader I mean the editing
okay first the editing of this is a
little [ __ ]
the editing of it with sometimes make
errand ball look like he's doing a
cheesy job but he's not
it's the editing of it where every time
they cut back to them and he's just like
looking up at you he does this like
squint thing with the one eyebrow mr.
white it's always his teeth in his
eyebrow yeah but yeah err Paul you know
he's the lead please Toby he makes a
good Toby he does yeah yeah he's one of
the few people who can convincingly be a
Toby he's the only really good actor in
this valley yeah they hire the worst
actresses for this film like they are
not good actors but Aaron Paul he's
great he has moments where he's playing
off Tony starts dad or you're like Tony
starts dad it's like the villain of the
story thank you doesn't play Tony
Stark's dad this is Marvel okay that
villain just cheesy as [ __ ] like he's
just a dick yeah this is like an
annoying douchebag yeah you're like how
did this guy have this pompous [ __ ]
get to be where he's at and why do
people like him and why do people
respect him and why is this idiot wife
with him like it was so dumb
oh man but the villain you don't like
him not because oh he's so scary and
evil it's because you're like he's just
a dick yeah and I want to see him get
punished for his dickish ways yeah and
like there's this one moment where Aaron
Paul and him they they have a
confrontation after Aaron pauses and in
a few years and Aaron Paul is doing such
a good job he's like freaking out he
wants to hurt him it's so real and then
you got this cheesy other actors what I
didn't think he was necessarily like a
bad this movie makes it at least for me
really hard to tell which performances
are good or not because so many other
things get in the way you got crazy ass
music to distract you and then you've
got weird editing to distract you and so
I'm like I can't tell now because the
movie itself is so cheesy that I can't
tell who's acting is just matching the
movie or is legitimately anything my
favorite actor this is Michael Keaton
yeah he is
so Michael Keaton steals the show
whenever he's on so yeah he's got like
his own podcast video podcast thing
going on where he's able to put together
illegal street races and the guy never
gets arrest
so why does he get OH
not make sense the movies so much but
it's always entertaining Aaron Paul has
a little posse and there you know
includes a black man this black dude
right he plays a black guy that's why
I'm saying the role they're like okay
every scene was like okay Aaron this is
like you spent two years in prison over
this guy and then you you just got back
in the team you're really intense Cudi
you're black
I gotta imagine black people are kind of
obsessive and he's like a professional
liar and I don't know he has like a
license for every kind of aircraft you
can conjure up like I don't know where
he just has like an army plane and he
has another helicopter it doesn't make
sense how he gets taxes how did he get
the news
70% of the plot in this movie is made
possible by somebody down the line just
not really caring about their job not
even on the screen but just like
whenever a major event it's like why did
they have two cement mixers probably
because someone was like yeah all right
take him
why is he flying an army helicopter
because his friend was like sure that's
why everything in this film is made
possible oh yeah at one point where Tony
Stark's day I was like I'm gonna make a
deal for you here's my offer and the
guy's a general dude I like the
supporting cast though I got like Aaron
Paul's team like yeah they were kind of
in a different movie because they were
kind of like comedic but there's this
one guy I don't know the actor's name
it's got like these huge [ __ ] high
balls ah he is funny in this film I
thought it was really I thought it was a
delight to watch overall it's a really
entertaining film and of course how can
we not mention this the [ __ ] car
chases no car races those are great
because it's not like fast and furious
out I like those films but it's not like
all crazy special effects and stuff it's
not ridiculous it's it's grounded in
reality you can tell there were people
really driving these cars they weren't
doing stuff that was totally like out of
this world like no yeah right like
overall it's like no you could tell they
were using real vehicles the whole time
the most expensive vehicles ever it is
really cool to see a movie that relies
heavily on stunt drivers and from what
I've read the crashes are like you know
shells like it's actual practical
crashing practical racing lot less you
know of that CG stuff and then it
odd that it's in this movie but it's
cool to see like I'm glad there are
still people doing that and who still
value that kind of you know octane the
main reason you're gonna go watch this
movie it's clicking call Need for Speed
by the way major disappointment for me
Aaron Paul does not say Need for Speed
at one point and I could have sworn he
was gonna say it real letdown but main
reason you're gonna go watch this is
because of cool [ __ ] car chases and
car race scenes and stuff they are
awesome like I gotta admit this movie's
a cheese fest right but the last half
like I don't know like 20 to 30 minutes
was really intense that actually like I
was hooked and I wanted yeah Aaron Paul
the [ __ ] one in the last car chase of
this film it finally figures out what
movie to be yeah and then you stopped
laughing ironically and you're really
into the race you like go kick his ass
man and it starts to work and that's
kind of what's so awesome about this
movie is that it's so silly for most of
it and I get the sense that the movie is
okay with that
yeah it's trying too hard but in a
really endearing way great finale
chasing it's it's totally worth it just
for that I'm glad I saw us in the
theaters to have seen that particular
scene it's effortlessly enjoyable
I like this film and I recommend you
watch it please do watch it cuz you're
gonna have a good time
get some buddies together have a beer
you're gonna have a good time now if
you're some stuck-up annoying douchebag
filmmaker who's a little technically
here's how the movie should be
constructed in terms of the scenes you
get yeah it's not for you okay stay in
film school and enjoy not liking movies
this film is just entertainment man even
for it's like yeah flaws whatever here's
my point the flaws are part of why you
should watch this movie yeah it's like
any any reason I could give not to see
this as like they just slide right over
into the reasons to see column because
like everything about this movie is
perfectly this movie okay so I guess up
for this awesome discussion we just had
it's time to give you a breakdown of
reasons to see this movie so I'd say a
reason to see number one Michael Keaton
I'm gonna go Michael Michael Keaton
above reason to see number two
I'd have to say the GAR sequence though
yeah cars yay our scenes are really good
yeah the car sequences are awesome yeah
would you say part three is I would go
for our Erin Paul for part three plan
Aaron Paul is pretty cool Aaron Paul is
pretty pretty awesome reason see number
four I'd have to say it's just a great
cheesefest yeah it's one hell of a
cheese fest and it's awesome to watch
encompassing a lot of the acting editing
done the score so it's it's like
anything you would say about this movie
that's technically bad I'm including
that as that's why you gotta watch this
movie what makes it entertaining so
those are probably the main four reasons
to check this film out yeah
all right guys thanks for checking out
our review for Need for Speed
why don't you scroll to that comment box
below this video and tell us what's your
favorite car action chase movie whatever
you know what I mean yeah and then when
you're done with that come on over here
and click this button that's where it's
gonna be I think it's gonna be in the
center now oh yeah there's a little
figure nothing you said it's click here
and you can see more episodes of reasons
to see last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of our videos
or reviews is out
subscribe subscribe man so you could
hear us talk more about awesome possum
lady blossom Buttercup awesome bubbles
bubbles yeah Powerpuff Girls that's what
we're referencing
Chemical X yeah sugar spice and
everything nice these were the secret
ingredients to create the perfect little
girls that Powerpuff Girl ice something
got [ __ ] up and Chemical X and the
Powerpuff Girl added yeah and then Bobo
Jojo the Powerpuff Girls were born
that's that's part of it I like that
show I did too that was the show that a
lot of dudes were like afraid to admit
at the time no it was cool see you're
getting two reviews in one episode the
city of Townsville that's what we used
to say all this is